[Music]
how's it going everybody there has been
a crazy new leak that has been going
around the internet the past few hours
it's an Avengers 4 leak of course and
you know with all Avengers for leaks
there's really no way of knowing if it
is legitimate or not but I have to say
this one is very specific and it ties in
well really well actually with other
events that have happened but as always
I'm gonna give it to you guys just so
you can hear it and hit that subscribe
button if you want to stay up to date
with more of these theories and leaks
about Avengers 4 Avengers infinity war
and all things Marvel DC and superhero
again you never know what's made up or
what's true so take this with a grain of
salt okay so the leak starts off with
what we really already know and that's
Avengers 4 will be a time travel movie
and it'll be due to Hank Penn's quantum
realm technology and that technology
will be introduced to us and ant-man and
the wasp so the Avengers are going to go
back in time and attempt to collect the
Infinity stones before Thanos does
however Thanos finds out about their
plan and goes to stop them according to
the leak the original Avengers will get
the most time which makes sense if you
think about it because they're going to
be the ones going back in time seen as
they're really the only ones alive after
Thanos to snap and not to mention that
some of the original Avengers contracts
are up and they have not renewed them
yet so if they will not be returning it
will make the most sense for them to get
the most screen time but also not only
will it be focusing on the original
Avengers but apparently it will be
focusing more on the relationship
between Thanos and nebula in this
different time slashed different reality
Thanos will essentially lead nebula to
believe that he actually really does
care for her but it's just a trick the
whole entire time he's just using her to
get to the soul stone apparently nebula
actually gets the soul stone and when
she gets it she uses its power and
realizes that Thanos was actually using
her the whole entire time and doesn't
care about her at all
now we have all seen just how much
nebula hates Thanos so imagine the rage
when she finds this out according to the
leak she's so enraged when she finds it
she actually traps him in the soul stone
then there's a really interesting part
that has explained in the sleek and I'm
not sure how I feel about it but
basically goes on to talk about the
power of the soul stone now we learned
in Avengers infinity war from Red Skull
that the only way to unlock the power of
the soul stone is to sacrifice something
you loved
however this leek says that the opposite
is also true you could sacrifice
something that you just absolutely hate
to unlock its powers I'm not sure how I
really feel about this and I'm not sure
that it even makes sense but again I'm
just giving you the information we go on
to talk about the final battle and
Avengers infinity war and it takes us
back to a condom this final battle will
sort of mirror the final battle in
Avengers infinity war except they're
going to win so it's kind of like
infinity war was the bad ending and now
enough pictures for we're getting the
good ending in this so-called good
ending apparently this is where all the
Avengers will come together to fight
Thanos and supposedly this is going to
be the first time where we actually see
all of the heroes together and the other
difference is that Thanos does not have
all of the Infinity stones so he puts up
a crazy fight because he is Stannis the
mad Titan but ultimately the Avengers
win but one Avenger
may not be there because there is
another part in this link and it's the
final part that talks about a certain
Avenger dying so apparently there's a
scene where Tony Stark and Steve Rogers
or Iron Man and Captain America are
stealing the tesseract in Avengers 1 air
but Thanos is on to them and he's about
to catch and kill Tony but Captain
America being the outstanding person
that he is steps up and says that he's
gonna fight Thanos one-on-one to give
Tony time to escape
Tony obviously tells Captain America
know you're gonna die if you fight
Thanos alone stick to our plan of
escaping and apparently cap responds to
us in the
was always the plan then apparently Tony
Stark will have a flashback scene from
the very first Iron Man movie where
yinsen sacrifices himself to allow Tony
to escape if this is truly the end of
the characters that we've come to love
such as Iron Man and Captain America it
would make sense to do flashbacks to
where it all began and I'm assuming that
we will get that for a Captain America
as well if he in fact does die so this
is the leak that's going around right
now
and again I've said it many times during
this video but take it with a grain of
salt but for Avengers infinity war there
were a lot of leaks going around that
ended up being true so you really never
know with these things and this leak is
very specific but that could all be by
design so let me know what you all think
about this leak hit me with your
thoughts and feelings in the comments
below and of course be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date and get informed about other
Avengers for news and leaks thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
[Music]